hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 19th of January today and you're
watching gamespot news project cars
which is Bandai Namco's entering to the
racing genre and not a new Disney movie
has brought their a game with graphical
fidelity the publisher released a
lovely-looking trailer for the upcoming
racing sim set to land on ps4 xbox one
pc and wii u on march twenty the clip
shows off the game's gorgeous high
powered vehicles from all angles and was
the tracks and weather effects expect
enough rain cornering lens flare and
artistic grayscale to have you actually
consider looking past the silly name to
pick this one up the cars themselves
range from f1 to hot hatches and
hypercars developer slightly mad studios
is calling the game the most technically
advanced beautiful intense and authentic
racing game on the planet that's been
tested guided and approved every step of
the way by both gamers and real-life Pro
drivers alike it will run at 60 frames
per second on Xbox one and ps4 and the
Devas aiming for 1080p in unfortunate
news a Taiwanese man has died after
playing games for three days straight
the 32 year old was found dead in an
internet cafe following what was
allegedly a several day gaming binge
according to local newspaper the Taipei
times the man was a regular customer who
often played four consecutive days this
is the second incident of a death after
a gaming binge to occur in Taiwan this
year and it is unfortunately not an
uncommon trend our condolences to these
men and their families and do make sure
you take care of yourselves when playing
for long periods of time finally a new
Sid Meier game is on the horizon with
the official announcement of Sid Meier's
starships the new turn-based strategy
game from the creator of civilization is
scheduled to land early this year for pc
mac and ipad the game has you
controlling a fleet of starships as you
complete missions to protect planets and
their inhabitants whilst building a
planetary Federation as you venture
through space you'll need to expand your
Federation's info
and reach their unique mission maps a
bevy of customizable ships and
dynamically generated tactical combat
let me know in the comments whether
you're keen on playing starships and why
or why not you can head to gaze up for
more stories on things like the order
1886 as pre-order bonuses and a super
quick dark souls 'speedrun that is it
from me today leave me your thoughts on
today's stories and I will catch you
tomorrow